it's time to spring clean not just your
closets in your home but your finances
we connect with our Consumer Finance
expert who shares why more people than
you may realize need to be doing this
right now
a whopping 73 percent of consumers are
living paycheck to paycheck citing
inflation as the primary source of their
financial struggles even people who are
making six figures over a hundred
thousand dollars are reporting Financial
struggles Consumer Finance expert Andrea
warrock says last year consumers racked
up more than 180 billion dollars in new
credit card debt the highest number
we've ever seen which means a lot of us
need help to spring clean our budget get
started by refreshing it go through your
monthly bills look for potential savings
or use an app like you need a budget
which will set alerts when you're about
to go over in any one category rethink
your cell phone data plan you may not
need unlimited there may be a lower cost
option for you mint mobile charges only
15 bucks a month and she says right now
you can try the service for seven days
also Purge any useless Services go
through any subscriptions or memberships
you signed up for recently maybe you
signed up for a trial and didn't realize
you were Auto enrolled up for free
Alternatives when available you can
stream some video content for free
through your local library's digital
platform you can use free perks through
current memberships through AAA and AARP
take advantage of the free local
activities and events to stay busy on
the cheap and you don't need to be over
50 to become a member you can get
discounts to restaurants Travel rental
cars and insurance programs and here's
something not to be overlooked look at
your energy bill get in the habit of
unplugging those unused gadgets do your
chores during those off-peak hours
energy will cost less during that time
and adjust your thermostat by one or two
degrees up or down and that can save you
a bunch of money there as well
work says the average American spends
300 on impulse buys every month so she
says spend time identifying those
triggers look for ways to eliminate them
for instance turn off those sale
notifications for the in-store apps
unsubscribe to the retail newsletters
and you know hey just avoid walking into
stores like Target you know just to
browse when you know you're going to
spend some big time money I feel like
you're giving me this advice directly
I'm going to take all of it advice to
heed there from Kirsten thank you